[Music]
you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with high triglycerides this
video will show you what they are and
how their levels are measured high
triglycerides can have harmful effects
on your body triglycerides are a type of
fat or lipid found in your blood your
body uses triglycerides for energy
one place triglycerides come from is
your liver
another is from the food you eat foods
that may raise your triglycerides
include fatty foods such as hot dogs and
tropical oils refined carbohydrates such
as french fries foods high in simple
sugars such as Donuts and alcohol
so how do triglycerides get to the cells
that need them triglycerides in food are
digested and eventually reach your liver
in the liver both the triglycerides from
your food and those made in your liver
are packaged together with proteins each
resulting molecule is called a
lipoprotein
the lipoproteins travel throughout the
body in your bloodstream
they deliver triglycerides to your cells
which use them for energy
or if you have more than you need fat
cells store the triglycerides as body
fat
if you are twenty years of age or older
the National Institutes of Health
recommends you have a blood test every
five years the test is called
a fasting lipoprotein profile during
this test a blood sample will be taken
from your arm after you have not eaten
for nine to twelve hours this blood test
can reveal whether your triglycerides
fall into a healthy range for most
people fasting triglycerides should be
less than 150 milligrams per deciliter
500 or higher puts you into the very
high range this means there is too much
fat in your blood
very high triglycerides can increase
your risk of pancreatitis and other
cardiovascular events like heart disease
ask your doctor what your triglyceride
level should be
in many cases lifestyle changes can help
maintain healthy triglyceride levels
these changes include eating a diet low
in sweets refined carbohydrates and
alcohol
getting regular exercise managing your
weight and not smoking
medications can also help treat impaired
triglyceride levels if your doctor
prescribed medication to treat high
triglycerides it is important to take it
as directed and report any side effects
you may have